so here's here's my question to all of
you should we just abolish the police
what do you think I don't think so no
well let me let me show the story City
Pages Minneapolis the City Council
members are considering disbanding the
police you heard it's no joke holy moly
there's they're literally talking about
straight-up disbanding the police and
they're talking about let me read this
they say the the City Council's
discussion is starting to sound a little
bit more like what groups like reclaim
the block and black visions collective
have been saying for years on Tuesday
Fletcher published a lengthy Twitter
thread saying the police department was
irredeemably beyond reform and a
protection racket that slows down
responses as political payback several
us several of us on the council are
working on finding out what it would
take to disband the Minneapolis Police
Department and start fresh with the
community oriented non-violent public
safety and outreach capacity he wrote
and then they have apparently this big
threat on Twitter it's an interesting
idea then I wouldn't immediately say is
the wrong idea okay not right no no
right because we talked about the other
day with black lives matter forming
their own community policing yeah the
only problem is they straight-up say
they want nonviolent enforcement or
something I mean what they said like you
know what is it transition will take
time vote and capacity blah blah they
mentioned something about removing you
know the force or something from from
police so that they're they're not
capable of killing people what would
happen if there's no police what do you
think I think man I mean I playing
playing Red Dead Redemption to pops in
my head because it feels it is literally
the Wild West you know you're riding
around you could you could shoot some
random person that's walking down the
road and just walk off and run off and
it's like so say that happened say
someone just saw you and shot you and
stole your wallet what you you you want
to call the local militia it's like are
they gonna be shooting at me I don't
know exhale the cops well yeah of course
I think I think maybe if we were to
outright just as ban the police maybe
doesn't make sense but they do bring up
transit a transition period and I'm
thinking about it now let's look you
know if I'm walking down the street and
someone walks up to me and shoots me
mm-hmm and I die right I Colin any
butter so this doesn't matter okay and
if someone you know what if you don't
die though and then I call the police
mm-hmm well they they rush in EMTs rush
in and take a report case closed
end of story hmm okay they're not gonna
find the person I'll take the report
let's say there you go so you know when
I hear from conservatives all the time
about defending your what's this what's
the saying when when when seconds count
the police were there in minutes these
are minutes away
yeah when seconds count please are
minutes away and so when I hear that
people are saying yeah defend yourself
then the police mostly just become kind
of a facilitator for you know legal
administration in the long run okay so
someone breaks in your house you kill
them the cops come they take notice and
they say okay and then they confer that
to the courts or whatever as witnesses
or as you know case or whatever or or
evidence for the case or whatever so
then maybe maybe there's something to
having the communities have to take care
of themselves like it's interesting
because we were talking about said the
day was black lives matter itself
accountability yeah the guy Hank Newsom
said he wants to have armed patrols that
would you know watch their own
communities so maybe there is a way I
think disbanding the place is wrong I
think that is a that is utopian pipe
dream okay and I think maybe there is an
argument towards defunding and reforming
that involves more reliance on
individual issues for more individual
responsibility let's talk about
qualified immunity yeah so what what
does that basically mean so essentially
I believe it was like 50 years ago
they passed this law that basically gave
all police members qualified immunity so
essentially if it essentially blocks
them from being able to get sued outside
like in a civil court yeah it can't be
sued go ahead here it says an ABC
Alberta here says yeah with police
misconduct in the spotlight the US
Supreme Court on Thursday will consider
whether to revisit the 50 year old
doctrine of qualified immunity for law
enforcement officers which has shielded
cops from civil lawsuits even in cases
where citizens rights have been violated
so even when
you know it's been a violation they
aren't able to get sued you know so if
they do look at this and and get rid of
this actually let me let me scroll down
I want to read something down here it
says cops basically act here it says it
tells officers that they can shoot first
and think about it later
now that is messed up if that's the case
because this that's basically what this
is doing it's protecting them like oh
you made a mistake
I mean someone died but we got you
you're protected and it's like no that
that should not be the case and if they
if they really at this and change it
that means they're gonna have to you
know every situation like man I if I if
I do this wrong my career's over and
that that's like pressing on every
situation then instead of going I'm just
gonna react emotionally boom I just
shoot because I'm you know my
Adrenaline's rushing and whatever it's
like they need to be trained they need
to know that they could be held
responsible and will be held responsible
I think that's a huge difference between
the way the police have been and what
this would mean man I'm kind of leaning
towards maybe we do need a fresh start
you know what what a fresh start sounds
good well whatever that means I'm not
entirely sure mm-hmm
but I've been thinking a lot about the
problem of government programs that just
keep growing and you don't solve the
problems all right you know my opinion
has always been like I think government
programs can be helpful can be very
important the only problem is that once
you create it nobody wants to let it go
because people get power and then why
would they give it up you know with with
the private sector used our Blockbuster
Video you become the biggest Empire and
video content in the world and then the
internet internet comes and you failed
to buy Netflix and you're gone you
forgot to tell everyone to smash that
like button wink so well yes smash like
button but no but but I think about
government and we create a program and
we like sign it to law and then it's
there forever exactly whether it works
or not whether it's outdated which a lot
of them are this is funny I'm seeing
this thing about disbanding the police
and it sounds absurd on its face but I
know a lot of libertarians who are like
yep get rid of a
the smallest possible government you can
yeah and we will take care of ourselves
I know people who move to Mexico because
they don't like the idea of police yeah
and they want it they want to be able to
defend themselves with their own weapons
and their own security well that line
there I feel like that's what would
happen to a argument is done oh no you
mean anti to a god anti to a argument is
just like nope mm-hmm if this especially
if this is where we're headed and it's
like okay yeah everyone should be armed
everyone should be trained it is it is
it is it like a utopian view where we
live in a world where crime disappears
because everyone's armed I don't think
it would happen no what do think so
here's what I think would happen I think
that if you were if the argument about
the to a actually really is resolved if
there's no more arguing about that and
we everyone agrees that we should get
guns and it would fit me start holding
ourselves accountable like the guy was
talking about from black lives matter
the other night then we could have small
police type forces like little militias
in each community and we wouldn't have
to have like a centralized police
policing so it could be very
decentralized
I think is a great idea maybe you
actually just need detectives for
investigating serious crime yeah all
right you know places like New York
you'd you'd need I mean like
white-collar crimes yeah but I think
states have their own investigative
bureaus who don't I mean that handles
that kind of stuff okay and local police
I think would need an administrative
detectives for paperwork involving
background checks and things of that
nature okay and then you have traffic
you know meter maid type duty stuff so
what would the courts before then you
know because no no I think the courts I
take a stronger role in that regard mmm
dealing with conflict between you know
when someone breaks in your house
because crime will still exist certainly
right exactly well but you know I kind
of feel like we can do better and the
tactics that have been used have created
this really impersonal and dangerous
situation in my opinion like that the
fact that cops don't care about you in
big cities yeah the big cities are trash
holes
yeah the force is too big absolutely the
people there's too many people
everything's so make it smaller but how
do you how would you do that this
building has you know armed people go by
like
almost like counties or like even
they're called wards I think in New York
I'm not familiar with New York I'm sorry
but I saw like a very small like
district almost it's like maybe like a
couple thousand people you could have a
small force that looks after those
people and they would get to know but
just like there's different precincts
right within Brooklyn there's many you
know in Manhattan you have like
different precincts of militia
essentially but but that's what the
police basically are I know they live
there they get hired they go work in the
office and you wouldn't know them
there's too many people maybe the
problem is too many people stacked on
top of each other in big cities that's
like sour milk that's a huge that's what
I was saying the other day it's like we
should not be reliant on cities because
living in a city forces you to be
reliant on other people you know we
should spread out
maybe cities are ready yeah I think they
are maybe that's the problem
I think so we're all on top of each
other people are trying to tell you how
to live but you have no choice but to
live in the spot we need Starling is
that what's called Starling StarLink
yeah Elon Musk say let's once we have
low latency internet everywhere yeah
broadband satellite anywhere anywhere
yeah then it's then it's amazing that
everyone connected we got to get rid of
grass start making food instead our own
food so we can actually survive by
ourselves I read on the internet that
you can pick grass and then suck the
juice out and you'll slowly die but
you'll die slower than starving oh yeah
thanks for that information well cuz I
was thinking about it because I'm like
I'm sitting I'm sitting here as the
world burns around me because there's
like there was a protest nearby here
yeah yeah and it was it was announced I
guess and uh there was rioting in Philly
it was nuts they locked down they shut
the bridges down and I'm like what do we
have to eat if like if everything went
up I'm like I look in the backyard I'm
like we got grass like can humans eat
grass no but you can take a nice bit of
grass and suck on them and you'll get a
little bit out of them so I guess the
diet deer people might have a leg up the
trans deer people will will keel over oh
not
all of them are trans what well they're
not trans trans human you're trans dear
transfuse their other kin all right get
it ro no no you're wrong wait wait oh oh
really I don't care another Ken are
mythical creatures oh is that right yes
oh excuse me sorry someone someone sorry
diva
to be fair I would say you're half wrong
okay so other kin are people take that
so so you'll see other ken where they
say like they're an Elvish Dragon Lord
whose name is like a Loras Herald of the
winter mist nice yeah you always come up
clean killer name I'd be a great d DM
yeah D definitely what yeah but I you
know they that's you know so the
transfer she's people are like the tiger
person yeah and yeah I mean you know
that's what they think so now there's
trans deer people if they ate grass they
probably just keel over and I can't eat
grass right right because humans can't
eat grass yeah anyway your point was I I
digress we should have ones we should
have we should spread out more humans
should not be centralized in major
cities totally it creates gigantic
refuse bins where we just dump it all in
the water in there and acidify the ocean
yeah people gotta gather those cities
and they're doing we have these major
farm operations that are ruining the
water systems yep you know it's not good
we need to reevaluate all of that people
are leaving the cities though right yeah
they're fleeing yeah well they were
fleeing even before this yeah and now
there's a serious mass exodus from New
York you know what thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you